io lo so che siamo nell'internet e
quindi cose strane accadono ma
ultimamente stanno succedendo un sacco
di cose molto molto particolari e
finalmente dopo tanti anni voglio
provare l'ebrezza di parlare di qualcosa
che va di moda online ossia quel brivido
che non ho mai provato di avere più
facili e quindi oggi si parla dell'expo
di milano 2015
eh eh lo so poteva andare peggio però
potremmo parlare di 50 sfumature di
grigio ma non ho così tanto bisogno di
news è comunque adesso che l'ho nominato
lo posso mettere nelle tag così arrivano
comunque expo di milano 2015 partiamo
dal principio che è o per meglio dire
sarà l'esposizione mondiale sul cibo e
che cosa è successo ultimamente che ha
mandato in soqquadro l'intero web per
caso il fatto che durante la lavorazione
i magistrati di milano abbiano arrestato
una marea di persone per truffa
no alla gente quello non frega nulla o
al fatto che gli espositori in questo
expo arriveranno da oltre 144 paesi
diversi e che nell'ultima riunione dove
c'erano tutti quanti i rappresentanti
non si parlasse altra lingua forche
l'italiano e il rappresentante del
bangladesh e giustamente alzato la mano
dicendo ma io non capisco nulla
questo perché non c'era né un interprete
nè una scritta tradotta neanche una
brochure di prova con una parola in
inglese ma no non è neanche questo
l'argomento chiave nella pagina facebook
dell'expo sono saltati fuori cinque
immagini rappresentative delle diverse
aree che ci saranno e lasciatemelo dire
ho visto il paradiso queste immagini
hanno fatto letteralmente esplodere il
cervello migliaia di persone e stiamo
parlando di un posto che hanno minato
universalmente magalli re del mondo e
che ci ha regalato perle come 10 ore
dell'avvocato de gli aristogatti che
invita la penna c'è gente del futuro che
ci invidierà questo periodo storico ne
sono sicuro
mandando nel particolare delle immagini
qual è la cosa che ha fatto sciogliere
il cuore dei visitatori della pagina
magari il fatto che nonostante
dovrebbero essere rappresentative di
alcune delle zone che ci saranno
all'esposizione non si capisco un cazzo
ne cosa ci sia né cosa si faccia magari
alla gente ha dato semplicemente
fastidio il soffitto di ogni singola
stanza o forse ma qui
hardware è il fatto che siano state
fatte con il culo è stato detto che
queste immagini sono state fatte da un
architetto che magari ci ha passato
notti intere e questo è il massimo che
potrebbe fare come lavoro e voi gli
state distruggendo tutti i sogni a lui
magari manco gliene frega di saper
lavorare con photoshop open toe in
questo caso e voi siete lì a ricordargli
come un fardello sulla schiena che una
persona inutile che deve morire
adesso non mi sembra il caso di volere
morta una persona solo perché l'avremmo
pagata fior fior di quattrini per fare
un lavoro di merda che poi per cosa
scusa per aver ritagliato male di
cartonati di persone solo perché questo
ragazzo asiatico in realtà non è
veramente seduto su quelle sedie o il
fatto che nessuna singola persona
dell'immagine non abbia la benché minima
ombra che la faccia sembrare realmente
lì solo per questa cosa qua ma queste
sono i mezzi e o magari che il metodo di
fusione tra il ciliegio il gazebo sia
stato fatto come se si fosse legato al
pollice avesse strofinato molto forte
sull'immagine e ognuno lo fa come gli
pare adesso stiamo lì a sindacare su
ogni cosa e vabbè si è dimenticato di
scontornare il bianco da in mezzo alle
gambe del tizio cioè tu guardandolo hai
capito che quella è una persona che sta
camminando verso un gazebo pasta in
questa immagine sembra che l'attenzione
venga data esclusivamente alla persona
in mezzo magari un parente cosa ne sai
magari l'ha messo per che assomigliava
ad alberto stasi o perché gli ricordava
vagamente il cantante de il volo cosa te
ne fregate lui ha notato la bellezza di
quest'uomo talmente tanto che ha messo a
fianco a lui una persona che gli sta
facendo una fotografia alle orecchie con
tanto di un watermark ma se non capite
il concetto delle immagini ma non
parlate per esempio un sacco di registi
francesi 50 60 anni fa quando
riprendevano i loro attori per strada e
c'era la gente che non erano comparse
vere e proprie ma erano gente di strada
normale che stavano camminando e
vedevano l'impanatura edward si giravano
per guardare dentro la macchina da presa
invece di oscurare i cluster eff il
regista di tenerlo perché faceva parte
del reality
non del tutto la macchina da presa
esiste non esiste così come il bordino
della scarpa di questo qui esiste non
esiste fa parte del realismo del mondo
ma che cazzo parlo a fare con voi che
quello che guardate di più su youtube
una cazzo di alpaca tutto allucinogena
per 10 ore
l'arte merita rispetto poi l'expo
contiene 144 paesi diversi e in queste
immagini si evince perfettamente la
multi etnicità dell'expo talmente tanto
che l'architetto voluto rifilare una
seconda volta una persona asiatica basta
col dire agli stranieri devono
rispettare le regole non è vero perché
noi non le rispettiamo il non rispetto
neanche loro è infatti l'autore ha
voluto rappresentare questa cosa qui
facendogli mettere i piedi sulle sedie
con tanto di risvolti mi el'importanza
concettuale di questa parte di immagine
è talmente ampia ed universale che la
ragazza seduta di fronte a lui si sfoga
dall'emozione e se anche questo non
dovesse bastare per farvelo capire
peperone sul soffitto peperoni sul
soffitto deve entrare in tutti trento
pick del mondo appena l'ho visto ho
chiamato un mio amico in via anch'io mi
sono fatto fare due finocchi sul
soffitto del bagno per dire ma se voi
non volete capire rimanete e dietro un
computer inutilmente a fare discussioni
che poi rimangono nel nulla
rimanete c perché secondo me lui avrebbe
potuto tranquillamente superarsi dovevi
far parlare dell'expo ci stai riuscendo
perfettamente ma spalle a mille queste
immagini non fermarti alle trasparenze
non fermarti agli scontrini che avresti
potuto fare con il lancio di photoshop
in automatico mai voluto farli con le
forbici dalla punta arrotondata 6
creativo supera i tuoi limiti
poi ci sono queste persone che si
credono ironiche che pensano di essere
divertenti gipo quello che ha fatto
trailer per l'expo con jean claude van
damme che gira in mezzo o quell'altro
che ha creato il generatore casuale di
immagini expo 2015 o addirittura una
pagina facebook che raccoglie tutti i
fotomontaggi della gente li mette lì e
queste tre cose tra l'altro vele lincoln
e le informazioni così magari ci date
un'occhiata il punto è che è inutile che
te ne lamenti seduto con il tuo colonne
sulla sedia perché io lo so che sarete i
primi
chiunque si è lamentato sarà il primo
poi ad andare a vedere l'esposizione
perché volenti o nolenti anche voi siete
sottomessi al motto dell'expo che cazzo
me ne strafotte a me l'importante è che
se magni